and you can't invest up here say she
said because you just never really know
what's gonna pop so when I got out I had
a 10-year plan that I wrote when I was
in there on what I plan to accomplish
come when I come out people always
ignored a gift not realizing that gift
us was gonna take you out of your
poverty take you out of your situation
everybody wants to be rich and famous
so get in line you're supposed to take
every situation and make the best out of
it I grew up in Africa where there was
no John run you just love great music
before that Michael Jackson gave me a
few tips awesome financial things too
that still apply
he's an American singer rapper
songwriter and businessman he's the
first solo artist to simultaneously hold
the number one and two spot on the hot
billboard list twice billboard ranked
him number six on their list of the top
digital song artists of the decade
he's a con and here's my take on his top
ten rules for success the key really is
to believe in what you're doing I think
a lot of invest in things they don't
believe in
but yeah bullet you know yeah I really
believe in it and the way to where
you're willing to put everything on the
line for them otherwise there's no
purpose in investing you know and you
can't invest off hearsay she said
because you just never really know
what's going to pop so ultimately you
have to know exactly you know what
you're investing that you feel like you
would be even if it didn't contain you
put money to and I think that's always
key you have to have the passion for can
you had some problems early on right you
had some time in prison we'll talk about
that later
what how did the rebound happen you what
this got a ten-year plan when I got out
I had a ten-year plan that I wrote when
I was in there on what I plan to
accomplish come when I come up you know
the goal is to stay out of trouble and
not come back into that environment so I
had to have a plan not the trouble you
know so ultimately that goal became of
course I started Konvict Muzik which was
supposed to be a concept that would
rehabilitation Vic's coming out and
utilize the talent that they have and
they just sprung into this huge
entertainment enterprise so before
prison no music was in your head no
definitely not in a way of making money
from it it was more as a hobby yeah so
what happened but what was your big
break uh the big break actually was
getting locked up believe it or not
there explain that well fortunately for
me my concept was always thinking big
and before getting locked up my goal was
to be rich by any means necessary
so they robbed the bank that's one male
Leicestershire that's a risky but what
was scary was that that thought crossed
my mind a couple times before and
ultimately was it like okay how do I do
it and get away with it and just made a
lot of bad decisions you know ended up
getting locked up which saved my life
once you get locked up for actually I
got locked up for a stolen car and a
concealed weapon how much time did you
do I ended up doing six and a half
months for that the judge was actually
lighter on me it starred the potential
so how did the edge felt there was there
a break in the first solo artists to
simultaneously hold the number one and
number two spots on the Billboard
100 that wouldn't guess you wouldn't
guess that for someone coming out of
first absolutely not you know what did
it I think it was more of the drive and
constantly recording constantly you know
just working towards that plan to one
day work with Michael Jackson and become
the biggest you didn't know him I didn't
know but you wanted to work with them
that was the time I was at the top of my
goal I said if I can shoot for the sky
you know at least so you said goals high
absolutely well my message to you pretty
much man is just to follow your dreams
another mean I think a lot of people get
caught up and using sidetracked by
what's happening I'm around and it was
cool
people always ignored a gift not
realizing that gift us was gonna take
you out of your poverty take you out of
your situation that gift of the choice
is an ultimate element that God provided
for you to get you out of any situation
or to take you to what you're destined
for you you know some people that just
create a certain things but because
music or modeling or film is cool they
alienate what their gifts are just to be
a part of something that is pursued to
be unpersuaded to be cool so I always
felt like you know my method and message
always has been they just follow the
gift that you have put a lot of
emphasizing
strain on what you feel that you're
great in because what you're grading is
always going to be what pulls you out of
the worst situations that you could ever
imagine it put you in a better situation
like Union today first perfect your
craft regardless of whether you're
single writer producer composer
choreographer you got to perfect that
craft know learn the business and people
always forget you're in a music business
understand how these contracts read get
the right people like management my
support system
all right attorneys know where is you're
getting into before you sign anything
what would you say to somebody that
wants to do what you did it doesn't feel
like they have the advantages well you
got to find your advantages mmm that's
the key because everybody I mean we all
come from different places different
backgrounds and we all have difference
between words and how we want to get to
where we going
but first y'all know where are you going
in all process so you got to know how to
get there like all I am an example to
what I like to do and what my dream is
but ultimately everybody have their own
dream as different ways to get them just
got to pay attention to your
surroundings and find the best way to
get there but you just can't give up
because everybody wants to be rich and
famous so get in line and you got to be
more patient anything because you can't
be so quick to judge I mean rush into
decisions you got to be very patient
know what you want and then just go
after it and then when it comes it comes
but it really comes he'll be ready for
it you know are you money driven no not
at all used to be though Josh used to be
now I'm not what's the drug now you want
to get over a lot of legacy now it's
about what did I do and how will I be
remembered when it's over
well actually carding out a fish I had
um
brought me some records on trade back
then when I first signed a card before
our best time and
I did I honestly did pass on it because
at the time he didn't sound like what he
sounded like the day best I've ever had
wasn't even it wasn't even close to what
that sounds like like I think he was at
a position where he was finding himself
and I kind of heard it in the music you
know I mean but ultimately as time goes
people develop they get better and they
become the best because of things like
that you don't mean like sometimes that
motivates you to want to be better and
take yourself yourself to the next level
and I think with him it was more like he
was turned turned around so like so many
times to where it became more of his
motivation you know I mean and that's
what it's supposed to do like you're
supposed to take every situation and
make the best out of it don't take it to
a position where you think people hating
or people don't want to rock with you
like that
it's just creating an environment for
you to be strong and make yourself
better and what it is that you do so
that's the OL idea and I think that's
what it was so I mean I don't regret
anything that any decisions that I make
because you never really can foretell
the future on what and who's gonna be
what all you can do is be as honest and
true as you can
and you know those words to carry your
way all the way through buddy My Mind's
always been open you know I've been a
music of God since a kid my dad was a
jazz musician I grew up in Africa where
there was no John run you just loved
great music so that was one of the
things I think would give me what gave
me the advantage even in the u.s.
because I never like you know paralyzed
myself to just one particular genre I
kind of took a piece of everything with
African melodies and just pasted it
together push come on boy love somebody
invested back into your career that's
the first thing you should do is
probably your publicist reason why I say
that is because the publicist is the
person that keeps you out there that
keeps the energy around you so people
can get to know who you're spread that
word on what it is you do what you
represent and it creates more of a fan
base that's curious that would one of
Italian T instagrams and the Twitter's
and the Facebook's to get to know more
about you and I think the more that
people know more about you the more
supporters you get and when you got more
supporters then they actually support
your selling which means they were
bought by which will bring in more money
so that you can hire a manager that can
help you manage that when you're not
only manage the money but manage your
career for the ultimately if no one
knows who you are and have no shot so
use that money wisely and put yourself
in a position where that money helps to
get you exposed oh actually it would
probably be C he's a good friend of mine
out of Nigeria he's in the oil
intervention
he's very very cute and he gave me a lot
of great tips
according today he's like more my
day-to-day finance mentor but before
that Michael Jackson gave me a few tips
awesome financial things too that still
apply daily
one magazine like sandwiches so long
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because mr. Furst Carlos
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you are going to
profile next leave in the comments below
I will see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of top ten
rules had the biggest impact on you and
why what changes are you going to make
what made you think leave in the
comments and I will join the discussion
thank you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
because if the route where I was
honestly and I continued that out you
know I wouldn't know why be today so
anyway so it was just obvious to me cuz
sitting up in there I knew this wasn't
the life that I want to do what's been
for the rest of my life but at the end
of the day I know I was between a rock
and a hard place because now getting out
with a criminal history you couldn't
work in a fortune 500 company or even
have opportunities to become rich as I
love the entertainment at that moment it
was like okay well I'm great at music I
love to do it I would do it even what I
get hate so that's when I created a ten
year plan in there and it came out and
started executing on it don't just do a
record because it's the hot record right
now you're trying to make one that
sounds like it assuming it's gonna give
you a better shot cuz it's not that
record is already there so your record
is not gonna make a difference so do not
try to copy what you're hearing out
there how can record companies become
profitable again I know this last year
they ate down a small very small profit
I think like 0.2% and I think it's gonna
get smaller
you know I think unfortunately as the
record companies they're not thinking
outside the box they're using old
methods of how they used to market
promote and they don't know how to let
that go
whereas the time is changing the youth
and listening differently they
understand music better than you think
they do and you just can't fool the
audience anymore I mean you have to be
able to take a shot and take a chance
you can't break anything that you don't
take a shot on and they're all chasing a
single records were built on an
experience artists and superstars were
built on the experience when you thought
about Michael Jackson you just think
about thriller or beat it or you know
human nature you thought about the
experience that came with Mike from the
performance to the many movies to the
concerts to barely seeing them in public
and you see them and chase them down
that you know alleyway that vision of
Mike was going to be there today and you
don't know if you're ever going to be
able to see them live again we lost that
that doesn't happen anymore because the
record company understood how to build
Superstars and you can't be profitable
if you just focus on a record that you
can download on I mean for free on any
music related site anymore you know so
and I think they lost sight of that made
and transformed into the digital age
fast enough whereas the younger youth
and the generation now understands how
that works
everyone has a Macbook where they have
GarageBand and can make their own
records and you have YouTube where you
can create your own videos and become
your own superstar so guess what if you
have that competition and yet the artist
that's making your money don't have no
extra leverage that you should be
bringing to the table and dumping the
money and the system that the average
person will have you're know you're just
as popular as the most popular person on
YouTube if you just focus on one single
record and a homemade video see back
then we used to put a marketing plan put
money into artists and create a system
that would make you want to say I gotta
go pick that up where I got to go see
that or what's coming next and how will
I be excited from it that they've lost
that